[Music]
in the mid 16th century
Italians were captivated by a type of
male singer whose incredible range
contained notes previously thought
impossible for adult men however this
gift came at a high price to prevent
their voices from breaking these singers
had been castrated before puberty
halting the hormonal processes that
would deepen their voices known as
castrati their light angelic voices were
renowned throughout Europe until the
cruel procedure that created them was
outlawed in the 1800s though stunting
vocal growth can produce an
extraordinary musical range naturally
developing voices are already capable of
incredible variety and as we age our
bodies undergo two major changes which
explore that range so how exactly does
our voice box work and what causes these
shifts in speech the specific sound of a
speaking voice is the result of many
anatomical variables but it's mostly
determined by the age and health of our
vocal cords and the size of our larynxes
the larynx is a complex system of muscle
and cartilage that supports and moves
the vocal chords or as they're more
accurately known the vocal folds strung
between the thyroid and a written oeid
cartilages these two muscles form an
elastic curtain that opens and shuts
across the trachea the tube that carries
air through the throat the folds are a
part when we're breathing but when we
speak they slam shut our lungs push air
against the closed folds blowing them
open and vibrating the tissue to produce
sound unlike the deliberate focus
required for playing an external
instrument we effortlessly change notes
as we speak by pushing air faster or
slower we change the frequency and
amplitude of these vibrations which
respectively translate to the pitch and
volume of our voices rapid and small
vibrations create high-pitched quiet
tones while slow large vibrations
produce deep bellowing rumbles finally
by moving the laryngeal muscles between
the cartilages we can stretch and
contract those folds to intuitively play
our internal instruments this process is
the same from your first words to your
last but as you age your larynx ages 2
during puberty the first major shift
starts as your voice begins to deepen
this happens when your larynx grows in
size along gating the vocal folds and
opening up more room for them to vibrate
these longer folds have slower larger
vibrations which result in a lower
baseline pitch this growth is especially
dramatic in many males whose high
testosterone levels lead first to voice
cracks and then to deeper more booming
voices and laryngeal protrusions called
Adam's apples another vocal development
during puberty occurs when the
homogeneous tissue covering the folds
specializes into three distinct
functional layers a central muscle a
layer of stiff collagen wrapped in
stretchy elastin fibers and an outer
layer of mucous membrane these layers
add nuance and depth to the voice giving
it a distinct tambour that sets it apart
from its pre pubescent tones after
puberty most people's voices remain more
or less the same for about 50 years but
we all use our voices differently and
eventually we experience the symptoms
associated with aging Clarence's known
as pres befo Nia first the collagen in
our folds stiffens and the surrounding
elastin fibers atrophy and decay this
decreased flexibility increases the
pitch of older voices but for people who
have experienced the hormonal effects of
menopause the higher pitch is countered
and outweighed by swollen vocal folds
the folds increased mass slows their
vibrations resulting in deeper voices
all these symptoms are further
complicated by having fewer healthy
laryngeal nerve endings which reduces
precise muscle control and causes
breathy or rough voices
ultimately these anatomical changes are
just a few of the factors that can
affect your voice but when kept in good
condition your voice box is a finely
tuned instrument capable of operatic
arias moody monologues and stirring
speeches at ted-ed we believe that the
time to share student voices is always
now and that every student has an idea
worth spreading find out more about our
student voice program and get involved
at IDI ted.com slash clubs
[Music]